are you going to make a contribution to
this country and then crucially there's
a second element to this too for me do
you actually know something about this
country and demonstrate a desire to be a
part of it and so this is where the the
question of Birthright citizenship goes
deeper for me
is I don't think citizenship should be
something that anybody automatically
takes for granted born here or not
I think every 18 year old should have to
pass the same Civics test that an
immigrant has to pass in order to become
a naturalized citizen in this country I
love that I think you got to know
something about the country if you want
to actually call yourself a citizen of
that Nation I think that ought to be
true if you're an immigrant I'd pull up
that Civics test not just from the
citizenship side I'd pull up a version
of that to the front end to even get
into this country it selects for people
who have taken the time to learn
something about the country who have
demonstrated themselves to want to be
part of the country and then yes to work
hard and be an industrious member of our
society contributing to our country